[Music]
i rule
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and today i'm going to go into
a story a tale
uh a beginning of the cosmic
and one of the best known stories and
retold stories
in the x-men history but before we get
started
let me introduce you to xm studio
phoenix a beautiful statue
something that i think every
x-men fan needs in this collection
is a phoenix statue because that's when
all
the x-men started to explore the cosmos
but i'm getting ahead of myself
let's go back to when chris claremont
and john byrne thought drink jean grey
was boring she was
a low-latent uh telekinesis
uh and a telepath i they didn't
really hint on her uh telepathic powers
more so until after this so
they were in this uh a space shuttle
coming back to earth and they were going
through
uh these rays and she was the only one
that can absorb the rays
as she piloted the ship they crashed
into the ocean
and um she emerged with this costume
what a way
to to to start a story it just seemed
like they were just tired
of uh jean grey and they wanted to give
her a boost they wanted to
change her look they wanted to give some
pizzazz to it
because at the time you had miss marvel
you had all these other characters that
were
that had flair that had uh
design and i think they wanted to move
away from the old costume design
plus booster powers up to make her an
integral part
of the team so this is part
one of the phoenix saga
so after the phoenix came up gene
automatically
uh goes into a coma and is bedridden in
the hospital
crazy but this is what happens
now at this time we already know
that uh cyclops is in love with gene
because they have a bond
but we found out that wolverine had a
thing for her
as well because he was going to the
hospital bringing flowers which he threw
in the garbage because he found out
everybody was there he's trying to get
there early
before anybody got there to give her
flowers and you know wish her well
well they go on in the story
her powers start to manifest and i know
you guys are more interested in the dark
phoenix
but we got a chance to see the phoenix
power
in its uh in this entirety
like um when she
was going against the hellfire club and
they met the dazzler
and the dazzler is one of my favorite
mutants
and she basically almost killed the
white queen
uh emma frost
crazy reed i love the hellfire uh
uh circle i love the hellfire club i
love that group
sebastian shaw all those guys is great
and mastermind is very integral into the
second part
of this absolute amazing story but let's
get into
this statue and what made me
go completely nuts from the engineering
to the flame to the phoenix
i thought i always thought that she was
on the base
but she's not she's actually in the
flames
the level of engineering is crazy
because she's coming out a sentinel base
and the sentinel base is very heavy has
a lot of gravitas
the same thing with the phoenix the
phoenix is a
very heavy clear resin um that you can
see through it you can see the
the reds you can see the arms you can
see the yellows
all in the birds you can see the bird
how beautiful it looks
and it all captivates and goes up into a
flame
a lot of people are at odds with this
statue
because some people don't like the clear
resin it looks anime to them
um to me the body style and the pure
costume
of her is very detailed very beautiful
even the phoenix emblem in the middle of
her chest
is done perfectly it's raised
it's a beautiful statue she comes with
three different portraits
now the portrait that you see here that
she has is the portrait i will display
it has very different hairstyles in each
portrait
one portrait has the hair laying down
the other portrait has the hair how i
would imagine
in the face scope of when she came out
of the water
and the last portrait my favorite
portrait
is the one where she's using her powers
you can see her the whites of her eye
eyes is whited out and she's actually
using her power and her hair is
up that's the one i will be using you
guys know i love
the og stuff when uh xm
used to give the coin the minted coin it
has the x-men
emblem there and it has uh the phoenix
in the front these coins are incredible
anytime you can get an og
uh statue from xm with the coin please
get it and you know just like thor says
lord vader says they also come with the
manual baby
um this is a part in the video when i'm
gonna ask you to
like follow and subscribe and hit that
join button
hit that join button you know where that
join button is that join button is right
there down at the bottom
so hit that join button so you can see
what we're doing in the realm
us at iop we're doing bigger and better
things
we're having incredible guests and also
go
to lordsofgaming.net that's our website
where you can catch old episodes of iron
lord podcast
the last word with lol cognito and
ibontis and
you can also get old episodes of kos
where you can see me talk about
different characters and different
histories
and the reason why i collect this was
the jumping part
where x-men went into the galaxies and
they the shia
empire and the galactic guard that stuff
was so incredible to me
i couldn't wait to bring the statue i i
definitely have to get it shout out to
spec fiction todd from spec fiction
there's so much great stuff if you guys
are looking for statues go to todd from
specs fiction
or you can hit me up because i actually
have statues as well
brand new statues from xm studios well
until next week when i bring you part
two of this saga
the dark phoenix there's no surprises
this week guys
next week you're going to get the dark
phoenix and we're going to talk about
the most incredible ending of a saga
or is it the beginning stick around
watch this statue in all its glory
and listen to some great music while i
see you
next week stay collecting
[Music]
yeah i just need
a little bit of patience you need me
i know that you've been waiting down my
number twice promise i'll pick up the
line
i see you're worried don't gotta ask why
you like
it i know that you like
it you like it yeah you like it
i know that you like it you like it
you said that you were down
[Music]
[Music]
setting you down
[Music]
and it might take a minute
[Music]
yeah you like it i know
that you like it you like it you said
that you were down just yesterday
hoping you'll stick around and wait for
me
[Music]
hopefully you'll be around for me said
that you were down just yesterday
hoping you'll stick around and away from
[Music]
me
[Music]
you